اذا نخصص هذه الفقره لقرار المانيا واشنطن
والدول الغربيه ايضا تزويد اوكرانيا
بمدرعات غربيه التصميم لانه حدد اكثر ماذا
يمثل هذا القرار الالماني اليوم يعني قرار
المانيا قرار المستشار الالماني الشغل
بتزويد اوكرانيا باربعين مدرعه من نوع مر
وايضا نظام الدفاع الصاروخي باتريوتلي
يكمل النظام الذي زودت الولايات المتحده
اوكرانيا به هو خطوه متقدمه جدا على
المسار الذي تبعته المانيا بعد بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا على الصعيد الدفاع على
اسرائيل الدعم العسكري الخارجي ورفع
ميزانيه الدفاع خلال الفتره الماضيه كوزيت
تعرض المستشار الالماني الانتقادات كثيره
لانه كان يتردد بتلبيه طلبات الرئيس
الاوكراني زيرنسكي بتزويد اوكرانيا
وبنوعيات اسلحه وكان يبرر موقفه بانه لا
يريد التصرف كالمانيا منفرده مع الحلفاء
الا ان الضغوط سدادت عليه من الداخل من
حزب الخضر من حزب اليمين المسيحي ايضا
وبعد قرار باريس في تزويد المدرعه
ويجد نفسه انه مطر لقطع هذه الخطوه التي
تمثل همم يعني خطوه متقدمه للغايه نقطه
التحول لك قد تكون في الدعم الالماني
العسكر انخراط العسكري لصالح الماني يكون
ايضا ياتي ضمن همم
قراءه غربيه لواقع الحرب تستدعي هذه
النقله
[موسيقى]
النوعيه في تصريح كيف لكن قبل قليل لان
كيف كانت تناسب مرارا يعني الغربيين بمدح
بهذا نوع من الاسلحه همم الرئيس الامريكي
شاركوزيت الى ما اعتبرهنعطف في الحرب
الاوكرانيه والواقع هو ان الاوكرانيين
يخشون الان من ان تبادل روسيا لهجوم مكثف
للغايه في مرحله ما بعد الشتاء اي شهر
فبراير واا دار المقبل وخاصه اذا اخذنا
بين الاعتبار التعبئه التي قامت بها روسيا
في 300,000 مجلد خطاب بوتين ليله راس
السنه مثلا بالصوره العسكريين وراء اهل
يقول بان هذه السنه هي سوره هجوم
والتصريحات الروسيه بكل الاحوال والواقع
في الميدان ومن هنا الدول الغربيه الداعمه
لاوكرانيا لا تريد لاوكرانيا ان تسقط
بمعنى انها تريد ان تقاوم اوكرانيا وان
تصل الى مرحله مفاوضات من موقع قوه ان
يكون ميزان القوه
الاوكرانيين عندما يحين اوان المفاوضات في
الوقت نفسه لا تريد الذهاب بعيدا في
التسليح بمعنى
الاوكرانيين الاوكرانيون يطالبون اليوم
بمثلا مدرعات ليوبارد التي الالمانيه
والالمانيه تتردد هل ستكون خطوه في مرحله
لاحقه سنرى لكن لا يريد لا يريد الغربيون
الذهاب الى درجه تحشر الرئيس الروسي
المصمم بكل الاحوال على اسرار هذه الحرب
اللجوء الى اسلحه نوويه غير في الوقت نفسه
لا يريدون لاوكرانيا ان همم تخسر وانت
تتمكن على الاقل من تفاوض وقت لا افق لا
لا يوجد اي معطيات تشير ان هناك مفاوضات
محتمله في الوقت الحالي لكن الاسلحه التي
زودت بها اوكرانيا تشكل كل الاحوال نقل
النوعيه لكن ليس بالضروره حسن الخبراء
العسكريه قادره على حسم المعركه لصالح
الاكرانيين بمعنى اننا مازلنا في هذه
النقطه التي همم يقول ديون انهم يتمسكون
بها انهم ليسوا طرفا لمهاجمه روسيا
لحشرها في الزاويه لدرجه استخدام اسلحه
نوويه وتكون الدول الغربيه طرفا في الحرب
ولكن في الوقت نفسه لا تسمح للاسلحه
لاوكرانيا بالانتصار بشكل حاسم هل ستتغير
المعطيات في المرحله اللاحقه اذا حصل وجوب
روسيا او غيره هذا رهن الاسابيع المقبله
لكن ما جرى في اليومين المضيعين هو نقل
نوعيه بناء على معطيات الميدان والقراءه
بان المرحله المقبله قد
ضروره دعم اوكرانيه حتى همم حتى تقاوم
الهجوم المحتمل همم وسيم الاحمر